This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1992, a historic election captivated the nation. The race pitted a young, up-and-comer against an old guard establishment candidate. And I am not talking about the 1992 presidential election between Arkansas Governor Bill Clinton and the incumbent George H. W. Bush. Instead, this was the highly publicized race between young Elvis and old Elvis. Best reporter Gabe Bullard. Over a decade after Elvis Presley's death, the King of Rock and Roll took overhead lines
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1992年，一场历史性的选举吸引了全国的目光。这场竞选在一位年轻的后起之秀和一位老派建制派候选人之间展开。我指的不是1992年阿肯色州州长比尔·克林顿与在任总统乔治·H·W·布什之间的总统大选。相反，这是一场备受瞩目的“年轻猫王”与“年老猫王”之间的较量。特约记者盖布·布拉德。在埃尔维斯·普雷斯利去世十多年后，这位摇滚之王再次占据了头条，
once again, as Americans weighed in on which portrait of Elvis would be forever immortalized on a 29-cent U.S. postage stamp. It was put to a popular vote. Should the stamp feature an image of young Elvis at the start of his rise or an older Elvis in his iconic white jumpsuit? The Elvis stamp boat grabbed the nation's attention playing out not just in newspapers and on late night TV,
因为美国人正在权衡哪一张猫王肖像将永远被印在29美分的美国邮票上。这事交由公众投票决定。邮票应该采用猫王成名初期的年轻形象，还是他标志性白色连体裤的年老形象？这场“猫王邮票之争”吸引了全国的关注，不仅在报纸和深夜电视节目中上演，
but in the actual 1992 presidential election. And by the time the final vote was cast and every ballot had been counted, US Post-it stamps have been changed forever. When you mail a letter, you have a lot of options for stamps. You can go the traditional route and use an American flag, or you can choose a stamp that fits your personality. The Postal Service has issued stamps for Selena, the Star Wars droids, the Simpsons,
甚至还延伸到了1992年的总统大选之中。当最终投票结束、每一张选票都被统计完毕时，美国邮票的命运从此改变。当你寄信时，有很多邮票可供选择。你可以走传统路线，使用美国国旗，或者选择一张符合你个性的邮票。邮政局已经为赛琳娜、星球大战机器人、辛普森一家，
and so many other pop culture icons. But this kind of hundred-flavor variety in stamps is pretty new. In fact, it wasn't until the mid-19th century that we had posted stamps at all. In the early years of the Post Office, mail was often sent cash on delivery, like a collect call. If someone sent you a letter, you paid for it when you picked it up at the post office. The postage was expensive, and the system for calculating fees was complicated. It was hard to know what a letter would end up costing in the end.
以及许多其他流行文化偶像发行过邮票。但这种“百味杂陈”的邮票种类其实非常新颖。事实上，直到19世纪中叶，我们才有了邮票。在邮局成立的早期，邮件通常是货到付款，就像对方付费电话一样。如果有人给你寄信，你在邮局取信时才支付邮费。邮费很贵，而且计算费用的系统非常复杂。很难知道一封信最终要花多少钱。
When the US implemented standardized postage rates, the cost to mail letters became more predictable and less expensive. Now, a person could pay to send a letter in advance, and the recipient could get it without a fee. A stamp was proof that a sender had paid for the mail. The US issued its first national stamps in 1847, one with George Washington and one with the first US Postmaster, Benjamin Franklin. In the decades that followed, the US issued more and more varieties of stamps.
当美国实施标准化邮资费率后，寄信的成本变得更加可预测且更便宜。现在，寄信人可以预付邮费，收件人无需付费即可收到信件。邮票就是寄信人已付邮费的证明。美国在1847年发行了第一批全国性邮票，一张印有乔治·华盛顿，另一张印有美国首任邮政总局长本杰明·富兰克林。在随后的几十年里，美国发行了越来越多的邮票种类。
Stamps marked anniversaries, celebrated big events, and honored historical figures. Presidents, military heroes, and national wonders, and technological achievements, and flight milestones. That's Daniel Piazza, curator of the philotelic collections at this Misonia National Postal Museum. For much of their history, stamp designs were traditional, institutional, and patriotic.
邮票用于纪念周年纪念日、庆祝重大事件，并向历史人物致敬。总统、军事英雄、国家奇观、技术成就和飞行里程碑。这是史密森尼国家邮政博物馆集邮藏品馆长丹尼尔·皮亚扎。在他们历史的大部分时间里，邮票设计都是传统的、体制化的和爱国主义的。
Because no matter what's on a stamp, it's still an official document issued by the United States government. Like paper currency or like a bond or something like that, it's meant to represent the country. And so putting someone on a stamp is essentially a government endorsement, and a lot of subjects didn't make the cut.
因为无论邮票上印着什么，它仍然是美国政府发行的官方文件。就像纸币、债券或其他类似的东西一样，它旨在代表国家。因此，把某人印在邮票上本质上是一种政府背书，很多题材都没能入选。
For most of the 19th and 20th centuries, America's biggest cultural contributions, like jazz, rock and roll, Hollywood, were mostly absent from envelopes. Part of it had to do, I think, with the fact that stamps in this period, most of them are designed and printed at the Bureau of Engraving and Printing, which also prints the money, and of course our money is very conservative as well. So there was a lot of hesitancy about getting into these frivolous topics. But there was also an incentive for the post office to design stamps that were new and novel. Because, along with the first stamps, came the first stamp collectors,
在19世纪和20世纪的大部分时间里，美国最大的文化贡献，如爵士乐、摇滚乐、好莱坞，大多在信封上缺席。我认为这部分原因在于，这一时期的邮票大多是在雕版印刷局设计和印刷的，该局也负责印钞，当然我们的货币也非常保守。因此，对于涉足这些“轻浮”的话题存在很多顾虑。但邮局也有动力去设计新颖的邮票。因为，随着第一批邮票的出现，第一批集邮者也随之诞生，
and they presented a unique value to the Postal Service. Postage stamps that are sold to collectors are pure profit for the Postal Service because they never have to deliver the service. Postage stamps are an IOU. Because of the way stamps work, as payment for a service not yet delivered, every stamp in a collector's album and not on an envelope represents money the post office gets to hold on to. A new stamp has the potential to make money, keep collectors happy, or even encourage new hobbyists to start a collection.
他们为邮政局提供了独特的价值。卖给集邮者的邮票对邮政局来说是纯利润，因为他们永远不需要提供投递服务。邮票是一种欠条。由于邮票作为尚未提供的服务之预付款的运作方式，集邮者相册中每一张未贴在信封上的邮票，都代表着邮局可以持有的资金。一张新邮票有潜力赚钱、让集邮者满意，甚至鼓励新的爱好者开始收藏。
And the Postal Service wants this. Since the 1950s, the Post Office has had Philatalysts, stamp collectors, sit on a committee that weighs in on stamp design. I think the needs and the desires of collectors figure fairly prominently in that, just because it's a, you know, as in any other business enterprise, that's a niche market, that's your base. And the need for the Post Office to make money wherever it can has only intensified over time. In 1970, Congress passed a law requiring the Postal Service to operate as a self-funded agency.
邮政局对此求之不得。自20世纪50年代以来，邮局一直有集邮者参与邮票设计委员会。我认为集邮者的需求和愿望在其中占有相当重要的地位，因为正如任何其他商业企业一样，这是一个利基市场，是你的基本盘。而邮局在任何可能的地方赚钱的需求随着时间的推移只会愈演愈烈。1970年，国会通过了一项法律，要求邮政局作为自筹资金的机构运作。
That means that all its funding, even today, comes from the sale of postage products. A hit stamp can be a big deal financially for the post office. But the USPS also has a fine line to walk, keep the stamps traditional enough to be fit a government document, and also keep the crowds of collectors happy with new stamps that generate money. To further protect the dignity of government-issued stamps,
这意味着即使在今天，它的所有资金都来自邮政产品的销售。一张热门邮票在经济上对邮局来说可能是一件大事。但美国邮政署也必须走钢丝：既要保持邮票的传统性以符合政府文件的身份，又要通过能赚钱的新邮票让广大集邮者满意。为了进一步保护政府发行邮票的尊严，
the post office also had a rule that anyone except presidents who's likeness appeared on a stamp needed to have been dead for at least 10 years. The idea was to give enough time for any unsavory details to emerge. The 10-year rule meant that a lot of celebrities weren't eligible for stamps at the peak of their influence, but it also meant that with each passing year, a new crop of honorees became eligible. Which is exactly what happened in the mid-19 1980s, when a group of dedicated fans started floating the idea of a stamp fit for a king.
邮局还有一条规定：除总统外，任何肖像出现在邮票上的人必须已经去世至少10年。这个想法是为了留出足够的时间，让任何不光彩的细节浮出水面。10年规则意味着许多名人在他们影响力巅峰时期没有资格登上邮票，但也意味着随着岁月的流逝，新一批受人尊敬的人获得了资格。这正是20世纪80年代中期发生的事情，当时一群忠实的粉丝开始提出发行一张“王者之邮”的想法。
I guess we would have been called stalkers, you know, but that word wasn't around then. This is Joan Gansky. She's been a fan of Elvis Presley since she first heard his music as a kid in England in the 50s. She even met Elvis a few times, hanging out outside of his house in LA after work. But most always, if you saw there were fans around, he would stop and talk to them. He never really forgot his fans. And his fans never forgot him.
我想我们当时会被称为跟踪狂，你知道，但那个词当时还没出现。这是琼·甘斯基。她从50年代在英国小时候第一次听到埃尔维斯的音乐起，就一直是他的粉丝。她甚至见过埃尔维斯几次，是在他下班后在洛杉矶家门口闲逛时。但几乎总是这样，如果你看到周围有粉丝，他会停下来和他们交谈。他从未真正忘记他的粉丝。而他的粉丝也从未忘记他。
Elvis died in 1977, and not long after after fans began agitating for a stamp. Joan and her husband Paul joined a letter writing campaign and recruited fellow members of their fan club, the jailhouse rockers, to help. They even made envelopes that said, I'm in favor of the Elvis stamp. We'd have meetings every month and we'd write letters and a big pitch was, look, you issue an Elvis stamp, you're going to make a lot of people happy, you're going to make a huge profit. And finally, the penny dropped with Anthony Frank. Anthony Frank took office as Postmaster General in 1988, the year after
埃尔维斯于1977年去世，不久之后，粉丝们就开始为发行邮票而奔走。琼和她的丈夫保罗加入了一场写信运动，并招募了他们粉丝俱乐部“监狱摇滚乐迷”的成员来帮忙。他们甚至制作了写着“我支持猫王邮票”的信封。我们每个月都会开会，写信，一个主要的论点是：看，如果你发行猫王邮票，你会让很多人高兴，你会赚取巨额利润。最终，安东尼·弗兰克听进去了。安东尼·弗兰克于1988年就任邮政总局长，那是在
Elvis became legally eligible to appear on a stamp. Almost immediately, he acknowledged the campaign for the Elvis stamp and even encouraged the idea. Frank's endorsement energized fans, but it also challenged the longstanding cautiousness the post office had around stamps. Until this point, the USPS had tread carefully, putting out commemorative stamps interesting enough to attract some new collectors while still sticking with their traditionally conservative look. If the USPS did put Elvis on a stamp, it would represent a fundamental change in what stamps
埃尔维斯在法律上有资格登上邮票后的第二年。他几乎立即承认了猫王邮票的运动，甚至鼓励了这个想法。弗兰克的背书激励了粉丝，但也挑战了邮局在邮票问题上长期以来的谨慎态度。在此之前，美国邮政署一直小心翼翼，发行的纪念邮票既要足够有趣以吸引一些新集邮者，又要保持其传统的保守外观。如果美国邮政署真的把埃尔维斯印在邮票上，这将代表邮票在
look like and who was allowed to be on them. Because Elvis Presley wasn't a war hero or a respected composer, he was a rock star, with a rock star lifestyle. A lot of the concerns around the Elvis stamp did center on his drug use, which was well known and well publicized and contributed to his death. That's Daniel Piazza again at the Postal Museum. After the Postmaster General said he would support an Elvis stamp, newspaper columns appeared with headlines like, return to sender. They argued that an Elvis stamp would be a government endorsement of drug use.
外观和谁有资格登上邮票方面发生根本性的变化。因为埃尔维斯·普雷斯利不是战争英雄，也不是受人尊敬的作曲家，他是一位摇滚明星，有着摇滚明星的生活方式。围绕猫王邮票的许多担忧确实集中在他的吸毒问题上，这众所周知且广为人知，并导致了他的死亡。这是邮政博物馆的丹尼尔·皮亚扎。在邮政总局长表示他将支持猫王邮票后，报纸专栏出现了标题如“退回寄件人”。他们认为猫王邮票将是政府对吸毒行为的背书。
This is the middle of Nancy Reagan's just say no campaigns. The thrill can kill. Say no to drugs and say yes to life. After school specials about latch key kids and getting into drugs and all this sort of thing. And it wasn't just fans of Nancy Reagan who had reservations about putting Elvis on a stand. Public Enemy Song Fight the Power came out in 1989, and it calls out Elvis for co-opting the work of black artists. Later in that same verse, Chuck D. also says this.
这正值南希·里根“只管说不”运动期间。“快感会杀人。对毒品说不，对生活说是。”还有关于“钥匙儿童”和接触毒品等内容的课后特别节目。不仅南希·里根的粉丝对把埃尔维斯印在邮票上有保留意见。Public Enemy乐队的歌曲《Fight the Power》于1989年发行，它指责埃尔维斯剽窃黑人艺术家的作品。在同一段歌词的后面，Chuck D也说了这样的话。
But despite resistance from newspaper columnists, anti-drug activists, and public enemy, Postmaster Frank didn't back down. In the early 90s, the Post Office began recruiting artists to illustrate a series of stamps that would feature famous musicians. As the art director told me, he said, we're kind of done with the whole poets and philosophers and presidents. He said, we're trying to go in a different direction. Mark Stutzman is an illustrator based in Western Maryland. He's designed movie posters drawn from ad magazine. And if you drank soda out of a Batman Returns Cup from McDonald's in the 90s, that was him. In the early part of the decade, he was one of a handful of artists tapped to submit work for the new series of stamps. And our director gave Stutsman a long list of candidates for stamps, including Elvis.
但尽管遭到报纸专栏作家、反毒品活动家和Public Enemy乐队的抵制，弗兰克局长并没有退缩。90年代初，邮局开始招募艺术家来绘制一系列以著名音乐家为主题的邮票。正如艺术总监告诉我的，他说：“我们受够了那些诗人、哲学家和总统。我们正试图朝着不同的方向发展。”马克·斯图茨曼是一位居住在马里兰州西部的插画家。他设计过电影海报，画过广告杂志。如果你在90年代喝过麦当劳《蝙蝠侠归来》杯子里的汽水，那就是他的作品。在本世纪初，他是被选中为新系列邮票提交作品的少数艺术家之一。艺术总监给了斯图茨曼一份很长的邮票候选人名单，其中包括埃尔维斯。
But they were toying with him not being on the list. Even at that point, they were really afraid of treading in this area for fear that they would alienate tried and true collectors. In fact, at first, the art director asked Stutsman to work on a stamp honoring Count Basie. But then a few days later, the director called back. They said, put down what you're doing, and I want you to submit your best Elvis Presley. And so after he got the assignment,
但他们当时还在犹豫他是否应该出现在名单上。即使在那时，他们也非常害怕涉足这个领域，担心会疏远那些忠实的集邮者。事实上，起初艺术总监要求斯图茨曼设计一张纪念贝西伯爵的邮票。但几天后，总监又打来电话。他们说：“放下你手头的工作，我要你提交你画得最好的埃尔维斯·普雷斯利。”于是，在他接到任务后，
Stutsman said about trying to capture the King's likeness in miniature form. Even though Posture Stamps are basically receipts for spending a few cents with the government, they're also works of art. That's part of what makes them so appealing to collectors. And like any work of art, they can tell a story. They just have to do it on a very tiny canvas. Stutzman was limited to five by seven inches,
斯图茨曼开始尝试以微缩形式捕捉这位“国王”的肖像。尽管邮票基本上是向政府支付几美分的收据，但它们也是艺术品。这就是它们对集邮者如此有吸引力的部分原因。像任何艺术品一样，它们可以讲述一个故事。它们只是必须在一个非常小的画布上完成。斯图茨曼被限制在5乘7英寸的范围内，
and because it would be shrunk down further after that, his art director told him to keep it simple. The format is terribly small and he said it can't be complicated, and my work has a tendency to be somewhat detailed, and all of that stuff. He says, don't make it, and he used the term fussy. He said, you can't get fussy, it has to be very direct. Still, Stutzman wanted to capture as much about Elvis' life and appeal as possible. So I had to rush to the library.
而且因为之后会被进一步缩小，艺术总监告诉他要保持简洁。格式非常小，他说不能太复杂，而我的作品往往有点细节过多，诸如此类。他说：“别把它弄得，他用了‘挑剔’这个词。他说，你不能挑剔，它必须非常直接。”尽管如此，斯图茨曼还是想尽可能多地捕捉埃尔维斯的生活和魅力。所以我不得不冲向图书馆。
This is before the internet. Rush to the library, go to magazine stands, get Elvis Presley fan magazines, and just start compiling as much stuff as I could to kind of see what direction I would go in. He read about how Elvis performed, where he got his clothes tailored, the color schemes of the era. Stussman drew young Elvis Presley in a gold jacket with a dark-fluck pattern in front of a pink background. His neck tie is loose, he holds a microphone in his hand, and he's leaning forward. I wanted Elvis' sex appeal to come through, because I think that was a big part of why he was so controversial and successful. And then I had the little tassel of hair that was loose that showed that he
这是在互联网出现之前。冲向图书馆，去杂志摊，买埃尔维斯·普雷斯利的粉丝杂志，开始尽可能多地收集资料，看看我该往哪个方向发展。他阅读了关于埃尔维斯如何表演、他在哪里定制衣服、那个时代的配色方案。斯图茨曼画了年轻的埃尔维斯·普雷斯利，穿着一件带有深色绒毛图案的金色夹克，背景是粉红色的。他的领带松开了，手里拿着麦克风，身体前倾。“我想让埃尔维斯的性感表现出来，因为我认为这是他如此具有争议性和成功的重要原因。”然后我画了那一小撮松散的头发，显示出他
was active on stage. And he's a little perspirey, but that's like two subtle for stamp worlds. Stutzman only handed in this one design. Other artists submitted multiple versions to the point that the Postal Service ended up with a total of 60 Elvis portraits to choose from. And I submitted one because I was young and dumb and didn't know that I could do more than one version. Of these 60 options, the Postal Service narrowed their choices down to Stutzman's and one other. The two finalists represented two very different periods of Elvis' life and
在舞台上很活跃。而且他有点出汗，但这对于邮票世界来说太微妙了。斯图茨曼只提交了这一个设计。其他艺术家提交了多个版本，以至于邮政局最终总共收到了60幅猫王肖像供选择。“我只提交了一个，因为我当时年轻又愚蠢，不知道我可以做多个版本。”在这60个选项中，邮政局将选择范围缩小到斯图茨曼的作品和其他一个作品。这两位决赛选手代表了埃尔维斯生命中两个截然不同的时期，
two very different versions of an American icon. When is the meaning of the young Elvis? Well, first just eye candy. Let's be real. Come on, young Elvis was super cute. And Powers is a critic and correspondent for NPR music. Stutzman's Elvis Portrait is of a poor kid from Mississippi on his way to becoming the biggest star in the world, powered by rock and roll. And of course, his famously scandalous dance moves. Young Elvis is, you know, youthful virility and spirit.
以及美国偶像的两个截然不同的版本。“年轻猫王的意义是什么？嗯，首先就是视觉享受。说实话，得了吧，年轻的猫王超级可爱。”安·鲍尔斯是NPR音乐频道的评论员和记者。斯图茨曼的猫王肖像是一个来自密西西比州的穷孩子，在摇滚乐的推动下，正走在成为世界上最大明星的路上。当然，还有他那著名的、令人震惊的舞步。“年轻的猫王，你知道，是青春的活力和精神。”
But also, young Elvis is irreverence. Young Elvis is, you know, wearing pink. And I think that's one of the great appeals of that image of Elvis and his youth is is that he is a soft boy that we can all love. Young soft boy Elvis was a far cry from the second Elvis portrait made by an artist named John Burkey. Burkey's design shows Elvis in his later years. He has sideburns growing past the high collar of his white leather jumpsuit. This quote unquote old Elvis is not quite facing the viewer. He's almost in profile. Berkey was reportedly inspired by an image of Elvis from his 1973 concert in Hawaii, though this portrait is widely associated with his Las Vegas residency. Berkey's old Elvis was closer to the one that critics made fun of. This was the Elvis who
“但年轻的猫王也代表着不敬。年轻的猫王，你知道，穿着粉红色。我认为年轻猫王形象的一大魅力在于，他是一个我们都能爱的‘软萌男孩’。”年轻的“软萌男孩”猫王与约翰·伯基创作的第二幅猫王肖像大相径庭。伯基的设计展示了埃尔维斯晚年的样子。他的鬓角长过了白色皮质连体裤的高领。这位所谓的“年老猫王”并没有完全面对观众。他几乎是侧面像。据报道，伯基的灵感来自于埃尔维斯1973年夏威夷演唱会的一张照片，尽管这幅肖像被广泛与他的拉斯维加斯驻场演出联系在一起。伯基的“年老猫王”更接近于评论家们嘲笑的那个形象。这就是那个
people joked about faking his death and hiding out in a trailer park. The Elvis who was immortalized in velvet paintings. Don't Gansky again. The Naseas they would bring out well you know that he was you know a on drugs he was fat and all these you know ridicule him for the jumpsuits that he wore. But even though Old Elvis was an easy target for jokes and was past his prime hitmaking years, Berkey's image was far more familiar in the 1990s. It's the image so many Elvis impersonators tried to copy. Even a decade after his death, this Elvis, with the sequins in the hair, seemed to be everywhere.
人们开玩笑说他假死并躲在拖车公园里的埃尔维斯。那个被永载于天鹅绒画作中的埃尔维斯。再次请出琼·甘斯基。“那些讨厌他的人会说，嗯，你知道，他吸毒，他很胖，所有这些，嘲笑他穿的连体裤。”但即使“年老猫王”是一个容易被嘲笑的目标，且早已过了他最辉煌的成名岁月，伯基的形象在90年代却要熟悉得多。这是那么多猫王模仿者试图复制的形象。即使在他去世十年后，这个留着亮片发型的猫王似乎无处不在。
In the early 90s, you didn't see many young Elvis. After his death, this Elvis, with the sequins in the hair, seemed to be everywhere. In the early 90s, you didn't see many young Elvis. In the general public's eyes, if you said, you know, you're going to see Elvis perform, they'd expect to jump suit. To fans, the Las Vegas residency, the tours, it all showed stamina and devotion to the people who loved him. The press might have dubbed this design Old Elvis, but he was only 42 when he died. And there was something poignant to the image of him in his last years, a flawed hero.
在90年代初，你没见过多少年轻的猫王。在他去世后，这个留着亮片发型的猫王似乎无处不在。在90年代初，你没见过多少年轻的猫王。在公众眼中，如果你说“你要去看埃尔维斯表演”，他们会期待看到连体裤。对粉丝来说，拉斯维加斯的驻场演出、巡回演唱会，都展现了他对热爱他的人们的毅力和奉献。媒体可能把这个设计称为“年老猫王”，但他去世时才42岁。他晚年的形象中有一种令人心酸的东西，一个有缺陷的英雄。
You know, it plays into this idea that wealth will not make you happy, that fame will not make you happy, which is always important to articulate as a kind of a safety valve for America's relentless craving for fame. You know, it humanizes the icon. The Postal Service unveiled Stutzman and Berkes designs in February of 1992. The young Elvis, full of promise and the old Elvis in all of his rhinestone glory.
“你知道，这迎合了这样一种观点：财富不会让你快乐，名声也不会让你快乐，这作为美国对名声无休止渴望的一种安全阀，总是很重要。你知道，它让偶像人性化了。”邮政局于1992年2月公布了斯图茨曼和伯基的设计。年轻的猫王充满了希望，年老的猫王则展现了他所有的水钻荣耀。
The Postal Service was already taking a risk issuing an Elvis stamp to begin with. To choose one image over another would be even more controversy to take on. Rather than make a decision, they decided to make a splash. The first rock and roll stamp would be a populous choice. By a mail-in ballot available at Post Office in April, the public will decide whether a younger leaner Elvis or an older plumber Elvis is the one that goes into circulation. Piazza says the choice not only let the Postal Service off the hook for deciding which
邮政局发行猫王邮票本身就已经是在冒险了。选择一个形象而不是另一个将带来更多的争议。他们没有做出决定，而是决定制造轰动。第一张摇滚乐邮票将是一个大众的选择。通过4月份在邮局提供的邮寄选票，公众将决定是年轻、苗条的猫王，还是年老、丰满的猫王进入流通。皮亚扎说，这个选择不仅让邮政局摆脱了决定该供奉哪一个
Elvis to enshrine. It also generated publicity for the shift toward pop culture stamps. It has this sort of build up leading up to the issue and the public feels involved in the stamp issue. You know, maybe part of the consideration too is that helps to blunt some of the criticism because it's obviously wildly popular. As hard as it might be to imagine, a federally sponsored mail-in poll about post-it stamps took off in a huge way, and not just among philatilists. Postcard ballots went out in People magazine, and were available to pick up at local
猫王的困境，还为向流行文化邮票的转变做了宣传。“它在发行前有一种积累，公众觉得参与了邮票的发行。你知道，也许部分考虑也是因为它有助于平息一些批评，因为它显然非常受欢迎。”虽然可能很难想象，但一场关于邮票的联邦赞助邮寄投票以巨大的方式火了起来，而且不仅仅是在集邮者中。明信片选票出现在《人物》杂志上，并在当地
post offices. People lined up to get them, some took stacks of ballots as keepsakes, or to try to sway the election. Just because this was a government vote didn't mean the usual rules applied. I voted at least a hundred times, and I suspect I'm not the only one. That's Paul Gansky again with some casual voter fraud. I think we all voted multiple times like on American Island, you know. There are a few reasons the Elvis vote became such an unlikely phenomenon. First this is when baby boomers were rising in political power and influence. Boomers were more steeped in pop culture than previous generations and they took it more seriously. Earlier generations might have seen pop culture as frivolous, but for Boomers,
邮局可以领取。人们排队领取，有些人拿了一叠选票作为纪念品，或者试图左右选举。仅仅因为这是一次政府投票，并不意味着通常的规则适用。“我至少投了一百次票，我怀疑我不是唯一一个。”这是保罗·甘斯基再次提到一些随意的选民欺诈。“我想我们都投了好几次票，就像在美国岛上一样，你知道。”猫王投票成为这种不太可能的现象有几个原因。首先，这是婴儿潮一代在政治权力和影响力上崛起的时候。婴儿潮一代比前几代人更沉浸在流行文化中，他们也更认真地对待它。早几代人可能认为流行文化是轻浮的，但对于婴儿潮一代来说，
it was generation-defining, a side-effect of growing up at a time with more mass media than ever. As the vote unfolded, people wrote letters to their local newspapers commenting on the stamp. Reporters interviewed impersonators, fans, detractors. The phrase all shook up was everywhere. It was anyone's guess which version of the King of Rock and Roll would win out. But one presidential candidate of that year made no mystery about where he was placing his chips.
它是定义一代人的东西，是成长在一个大众媒体比以往任何时候都多的时代的副作用。随着投票的展开，人们写信给当地报纸评论邮票。记者采访了模仿者、粉丝、反对者。“All Shook Up”这个短语随处可见。谁也猜不到摇滚之王的哪个版本会胜出。但那年的一位总统候选人毫不掩饰他把筹码押在了哪里。
Bill Clinton of Arkansas has been nicknamed Elvis by reporters, a man who would be president as a fan of the king and he was persuading. Clinton was in his 40s, old for an Elvis, but young for a presidential candidate. And like other baby boomers, he engaged with pop culture in a new way. He went on MTV, he used Fleetwood Mac for his campaign song, and he loved Elvis. Clinton welcomed the comparisons. The press called his plane, air Elvis, and he sang Elvis on the campaign trail.
阿肯色州的比尔·克林顿被记者戏称为“猫王”，这位想成为总统的人是这位国王的粉丝，而且他很有说服力。克林顿40多岁，对于猫王来说太老了，但对于总统候选人来说还很年轻。像其他婴儿潮一代一样，他以一种新的方式参与流行文化。他上了MTV，用Fleetwood Mac的歌作为竞选歌曲，他热爱埃尔维斯。克林顿欢迎这种比较。媒体称他的飞机为“空军猫王”，他在竞选活动中演唱埃尔维斯的歌。
No, I can't be found. That's all I can do. Sit home all alone. If you can't come around, at least please telephone my message to the New York press. Don't be cruel. But I'm too horny. And on top of that, Clinton referenced Elvis during one of the most iconic campaign appearances in political history. The Arseneo Hall Show opens and bears Bill Clinton, wearing sunglasses and playing saxophone with the show's band. This was in June of 92, the day after Clinton secured the Democratic nomination, and just as Arsenio walks on stage waving, Clinton starts playing a solo.
“不，我找不到。我能做的就是独自坐在家里。如果你不能过来，至少请打电话给纽约媒体传个话。别太残忍。但我太渴望了。”最重要的是，克林顿在政治史上最具标志性的竞选亮相之一中提到了埃尔维斯。《阿塞尼奥·霍尔秀》开场，比尔·克林顿戴着墨镜，与节目的乐队一起演奏萨克斯风。那是在92年6月，克林顿获得民主党提名后的第二天，就在阿塞尼奥挥手走上舞台时，克林顿开始演奏独奏。
The song he's playing is, of course, Heartbreak Hotel hotel by Elvis Presley. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ OUTRO MUSIC [♪ OUTRO MUSIC [♪ OUTRO MUSIC [♪ OUTRO MUSIC [♪ OUTRO MUSIC [♪ Arseniel Hall asked Clinton was about the Alpha Stamp. Let's get right down to things. What do you like? The Old Elvis or the... Wood Stamp. You know, I know you're an Elvis fan. I led a national crusade for the young Elvis. Really?
他演奏的歌曲当然是埃尔维斯·普雷斯利的《伤心旅馆》。阿塞尼奥·霍尔问克林顿关于猫王邮票的事。“让我们直接进入正题。你喜欢哪一个？年老的猫王还是……年轻的猫王？你知道，我知道你是猫王的粉丝。”“我领导了一场为年轻猫王的全国性运动。”“真的吗？”
Yeah. You know, and you get old, you... I mean, he got fat like me. I mean, you know, I... I think it has to be the young elephant. That's when he had all his energy and real raw, new fresh power. I mean, you know, it would be ashamed to do the old thing. The public didn't need to wait long to find out if Bill Clinton's prediction would bear out.
“是的。你知道，当你变老时，你……我的意思是，他变得像我一样胖。我的意思是，你知道，我……我认为必须是年轻的猫王。那是他拥有所有能量和真正原始、新鲜力量的时候。我的意思是，你知道，做年老的样子会很丢脸。”公众不需要等太久就知道比尔·克林顿的预测是否会实现。
Because the next day in Memphis, they announced the results. 1.2 million ballots were cast for the OVIS stamp, and at the podium in front of network cameras, Anthony Frank made the announcement. The winner is... It is... The young Elvis. Young Elvis won by a landslide, taking 75% of the vote. Speaking to reporters the day of the unveiling, Postmaster Frank used this attention to say
因为第二天在孟菲斯，他们宣布了结果。120万张选票投给了“年老猫王”邮票，在网络摄像机前的讲台上，安东尼·弗兰克宣布了结果。“获胜者是……它是……年轻的猫王。”年轻的猫王以压倒性优势获胜，获得了75%的选票。在揭幕当天对记者发表讲话时，弗兰克局长利用这种关注说
the stamp was the start of a change for the post office. We're not elitist anymore and we're not only doing symphonies and we're not only doing dead poets, but we're doing people that contributed to the culture of our country, the pop culture of you will. The Elvis Stamp went on sale just a couple weeks before Clinton's inauguration on what would have been Elvis' 58th birthday. The Ganskies were in line, along with thousands of other fans. I know I bought at least 50 sheets.
这张邮票是邮局变革的开始。“我们不再是精英主义者了，我们不仅在做交响乐，也不仅在做已故的诗人，我们在做那些为我们国家的文化做出贡献的人，如果你愿意的话，就是流行文化。”猫王邮票在克林顿就职典礼前几周，也就是埃尔维斯58岁生日那天开始发售。甘斯基夫妇排在队伍中，还有成千上万的其他粉丝。“我知道我至少买了50张整版。”
I seem to recolorating a check for $700. That's a lot of money back then. I seem to recolorating a check for $700. That's a lot of money back then. Stamps were 29 cents. And the post office went on to sell over a half a billion Elvis stamps. It outsold every single commemorative stamp before and since. And with many of those stamps heading towards collectors albums, that was a lot of profits for the Postal Service. A few people didn't like the idea of Elvis being on his stamp, but what the hell?
“我似乎记得开了一张700美元的支票。那在当时是一大笔钱。”邮票是29美分。邮局最终卖出了超过5亿张猫王邮票。它的销量超过了之前和之后的所有纪念邮票。随着许多邮票进入集邮者的相册，这对邮政局来说是巨大的利润。少数人不喜欢埃尔维斯登上邮票的想法，但管他呢？
It worked out good. On top of the stamp sales, the post office also made money, licensing Stutzman's young Elvis image. There were mugs and key chains and I don't know, belt buckles and tote bags and probably baseball caps and who knows what else. Soon, the post office launched the Legends of American Music series, with stamps for Otis Redding, Buddy Holly, Bill Haley, Dina Washington, and of course Elvis. The series went on to include over 70 artists and opened the doors to a whole new wave of black musicians on US stamps. Since the Elvis Stamp came out, a lot of concerns about
结果很好。除了邮票销售外，邮局还通过授权斯图茨曼的年轻猫王形象赚了钱。有马克杯、钥匙扣，还有什么，皮带扣、手提袋，可能还有棒球帽，谁知道呢。很快，邮局推出了“美国音乐传奇”系列，为奥蒂斯·雷丁、巴迪·霍利、比尔·哈利、迪娜·华盛顿，当然还有埃尔维斯发行了邮票。该系列后来包括了70多位艺术家，并为美国邮票上的一大批黑人音乐家打开了大门。自从猫王邮票发行以来，许多关于
propriety have gone out the window. Famously, anti-drug artists like Jimmy Hendrix and Janice Joplin got stamps with little to no blowback. So have movie stars, athletes, and even cartoon characters. Stamps were never the same again. This absolutely opened the door to the pop culture stamps of the 20th century. For good or ill, I mean, whether you like that or not.
得体性的担忧已经烟消云散。众所周知，像吉米·亨德里克斯和贾尼斯·乔普林这样的反毒品艺术家获得了邮票，几乎没有受到任何反弹。电影明星、运动员甚至卡通人物也是如此。邮票再也不一样了。这绝对为20世纪的流行文化邮票打开了大门。无论好坏，我的意思是，无论你是否喜欢。
America might not have been ready in 1992, but today, I think it's safe to say that an old Elvis stamp would be an easy sell for the post office. Jump suit and all. C.C.C.L. for the post office. Jump suit and all. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Coming up the strange world of international Elvis stamps.
美国在1992年可能还没有准备好，但今天，我认为可以肯定地说，一张年老的猫王邮票对邮局来说很容易卖出去。连体裤什么的都算上。接下来是国际猫王邮票的奇异世界。
[♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ So we're back with Gabe Bollard and Gabe, we were talking about the Elvis stamp, but I should specify it, we're talking about the US Elvis stamp because the one you reported on is not the only Elvis stamp out there. It isn't the only one, and it's not even the first.
我们又回到了盖布·布拉德身边。盖布，我们一直在谈论猫王邮票，但我应该明确一下，我们谈论的是美国猫王邮票，因为你报道的那张并不是唯一的猫王邮票。它不是唯一的，甚至不是第一张。
Other countries without the same dead for so many years rule as the US issued their own Elva stamps years earlier. And so how many are there? So there are dozens out there issued over decades. The earliest I can find was issued in Grenada one year after Elva's died in August 1978. But there have also been Elva stamps in Tanzania, West Germany, Central African Republic, and many other countries.
其他没有美国那种“去世多年”规则的国家，早在几年前就发行了自己的猫王邮票。那么有多少张呢？有几十张，几十年来发行的。我能找到的最早的一张是埃尔维斯去世一年后，即1978年8月在格林纳达发行的。但坦桑尼亚、西德、中非共和国和许多其他国家也发行过猫王邮票。
And I'm guessing these various Elvis stamps from like Grenada are big among collectors. Yeah, to say the least. Jason Cardavni, he's a historian and a stamp collector who specializes in music stamps. He showed me his collection. I have a whole album of postage stamps of Elvis from all over the world, and it's just it's incredible. I mean, Albania, Antigua, Chad, Burkina Faso, I mean, just all of these countries featuring Elvis, and you know that they're doing it for monetary reasons.
我猜这些来自格林纳达等地的各种猫王邮票在集邮者中很受欢迎。是的，至少可以这么说。杰森·卡达夫尼是一位历史学家和专门研究音乐邮票的集邮者。他向我展示了他的收藏。“我有一整本来自世界各地的猫王邮票，这简直太不可思议了。我的意思是，阿尔巴尼亚、安提瓜、乍得、布基纳法索，我的意思是，所有这些国家都以埃尔维斯为特色，你知道他们这样做是出于金钱原因。”
It's kind of funny and interesting. And so what do these stamps look like? I mean, did they all decide to do the young Elvis like we did? No, no, not at all. They run the gamut of Elvis's career and meaning. There are young, old, there's tributes to different movies he was in, there's tributes to events in his life.
这既有趣又引人入胜。那么这些邮票长什么样？我的意思是，他们是否都决定像我们一样做年轻的猫王？不，完全不是。它们涵盖了埃尔维斯职业生涯和意义的方方面面。有年轻的、年老的，有对他参演的不同电影的致敬，有对他生活中事件的致敬。
There's a postage stamp of Elvis that actually celebrates his service in the military. So it's an image of him holding a gun, actually the stamp itself, and then him in a young uniform there, just sort of in a collector souvenir sheet around it. That's from Liberia. So yeah, so there's some interesting, kind of graphic treatments of Elvis in these global stamps. So is this a widespread thing to have US celebrities on international stamps?
有一张埃尔维斯邮票实际上是为了庆祝他在军队服役。所以这是一张他拿着枪的形象，实际上是邮票本身，然后是他年轻时穿着制服的样子，只是在周围的集邮纪念张里。那是来自利比里亚的。所以是的，这些全球邮票中对埃尔维斯有一些有趣的图形处理。那么，让美国名人在国际邮票上出现是一种普遍现象吗？
Or is this just like the magic of Elvis? Is this just an Elvis thing? So Elvis changed the game for stamps like this, but he's not the only American celebrity you'll see. To go back a bit, Jason says Lewis Armstrong was on other country stamps long before Elvis. Within a few months of his death in 1971, Molly, Senegal, and a few other countries put
还是这只是猫王的魔力？这只是猫王的事情吗？所以埃尔维斯改变了这类邮票的游戏规则，但他不是你看到的唯一一位美国名人。回溯一下，杰森说路易斯·阿姆斯特朗在猫王之前很久就出现在其他国家的邮票上了。在他1971年去世后的几个月内，马里、塞内加尔和其他几个国家就发行了
out stamps with Armstrong on him. I think part of that was the sensation that he was, and jazz was so big in Africa. Part of it was the sort of growth of the black power movement and looking at black diaspora writ large and sort of champion champion these figures across international boundaries. So some of these countries are putting US figures on their stamps because they have some sort of ideological connection. Like it's essentially an honor. But as Jason kind of mentioned, you got to imagine that this is also a ploy to make money, right? Oh, yeah. Yeah.
印有阿姆斯特朗的邮票。我认为部分原因是他的轰动效应，而且爵士乐在非洲非常流行。部分原因是黑人权力运动的增长，以及对黑人侨民的广泛关注，并在国际边界上支持这些人物。所以其中一些国家把美国人物印在邮票上是因为他们有某种意识形态联系。就像这本质上是一种荣誉。但正如杰森提到的，你得想象这也是一种赚钱的策略，对吧？哦，是的。是的。
One reason to put out stamps with US figures is because the stamps will sell to US collectors. And the US Elvis stamp made it clear just how much money a pop culture stamp can make. Jason says there's this wave of foreign stamps for US pop culture after the young Elvis stamp in the US was such a hit. And so can you tell me a little bit about what these international stamps typically look like? Are they, are there any sort of like different or interesting aesthetic choices that they make versus US stamps? Oh yeah, there's a wide variety of designs.
发行印有美国人物的邮票的一个原因是这些邮票会卖给美国集邮者。而美国猫王邮票清楚地表明了流行文化邮票能赚多少钱。杰森说，在美国的年轻猫王邮票大获成功后，出现了一波针对美国流行文化的外国邮票浪潮。那么你能告诉我这些国际邮票通常长什么样吗？它们与美国邮票相比，有什么不同或有趣的审美选择吗？哦，是的，设计种类繁多。
If you go on to stamp buying websites, you'll see a lot of what they call souvenir sheets with a few different faces on them. Typically when you think of a sheet of stamps, you might think of a tight grid without much space that isn't dedicated to postage. That's how you buy them at the post office here. But souvenir sheets are pages, sometimes they're postcard size, sometimes they're larger, that are meant for collectors. They only have a few stamps on them, but with an illustration around them that expands on the design. So if a stamp is someone's face,
如果你去邮票购买网站，你会看到很多他们所谓的“纪念张”，上面有几个不同的人脸。通常当你想到一版邮票时，你可能会想到一个紧密的网格，没有太多不专门用于邮资的空间。这就是你在邮局买到的方式。但纪念张是页面，有时是明信片大小，有时更大，是为集邮者准备的。它们上面只有几张邮票，但周围有插图，扩展了设计。所以如果一张邮票是一个人的脸，
the souvenir sheet might show the rest of their body. And relevant to our story about Bill Clinton and Elvis, Jason has a souvenir sheet with two stamps on it. This is from Chad. It's two stamps but they're next to each other. And it's an older Elvis wearing one of his jumpsuits, playing guitar, but he's standing next to Bill Clinton playing saxophone. So old Elvis and Clinton, even though Clinton mentioned that he actually preferred the young Elvis. Exactly. Exactly.
纪念张可能会展示他们的身体其余部分。关于我们对比尔·克林顿和埃尔维斯的故事，杰森有一张上面有两张邮票的纪念张。这是来自乍得的。这是两张邮票，但它们挨在一起。是一个穿着连体裤、弹着吉他的年老埃尔维斯，但他旁边站着弹萨克斯风的比尔·克林顿。所以是年老的猫王和克林顿，尽管克林顿提到他实际上更喜欢年轻的猫王。正是如此。正是如此。
And there's a lot of pairings. Paul and Joan and fellow producers, Selena, Sayah Reynolds looked through a lot of these stamps spotting different celebrities. Since his Robert Redford, Marilyn Monroe. Michelle Fiverr. Ms. Taylor. Eddie Murphy. Redford, Maryland, and Rome. Which I'll fight for. Mm-hmm, this tailor. Eddie Murphy. Oh, Eddie Murphy, yeah.
而且有很多配对。保罗和琼以及制片人赛琳娜、萨亚·雷诺兹看了很多这些邮票，发现了不同的名人。这是罗伯特·雷德福、玛丽莲·梦露。米歇尔·菲佛。泰勒女士。艾迪·墨菲。雷德福、玛丽莲和梦露。我会为之奋斗的。嗯，泰勒女士。艾迪·墨菲。哦，艾迪·墨菲，是的。
That's a huge variety of people. Many of them living. That's impressive. It is, it is. And I do want to highlight that there's some controversy around this. So there are some fakes out there where a printer just puts a government's name on a stamp. And there are times when a company completely outside of a country might be in charge of issuing or designing commemorative postage, but with the approval of the country. And sometimes a company might have a contract to make stamps, but they don't really mean
那是一个非常多样化的人群。其中许多人还活着。这令人印象深刻。确实，确实。而且我想强调的是，这周围有一些争议。所以有一些假货，打印机只是把政府的名字印在邮票上。有时，一个完全在国家之外的公司可能负责发行或设计纪念邮票，但得到了该国的批准。有时一家公司可能有制作邮票的合同，但他们并不真的打算
for them to ever be used to send letters. Oh, so there might be stamps that bear the country's name, but they never really appear in that country at all. Like they're specifically meant to just attract collectors. Yeah, and there's a term for this kind of stamp. It's called a speculative stamp, and collectors are divided on these. So it went away. Well, so it could be seen as excessive among some collectors, and this debate goes back
让它们被用来寄信。哦，所以可能有一些邮票带有国家的名字，但它们从未真正出现在那个国家。就像它们专门为了吸引集邮者一样。是的，这种邮票有一个术语。它被称为“投机性邮票”，集邮者对这些邮票有分歧。所以它消失了。好吧，所以它在一些集邮者中可能被视为过分，而这种争论可以追溯到
a long way. When the US issued its first commemorative stamps to mark the Colombian exposition in 1893, there was briefly a group called the Society for the Suppression of Speculative Stamps that told collectors not to buy these, but that grouped in last very long. The SSS didn't just take off. Light the world on fire. Okay. Okay. So some collectors, they still want speculative stamps,
很久以前。当美国在1893年发行第一批纪念哥伦布博览会的邮票时，曾短暂出现过一个名为“抑制投机性邮票协会”的组织，告诉集邮者不要购买这些邮票，但那个组织并没有持续太久。SSS并没有真正火起来。点燃世界。好吧。好吧。所以一些集邮者，他们仍然想要投机性邮票，
even though those stamps might not be meant for the actual purpose of stamps, which is to move mail in the country that they're issued. Exactly, yeah. And these stamps, even if they're controversial, they're really interesting to see, because US pop culture doesn't just exist in the US. It's an international export.
即使这些邮票可能不是为了邮票的实际目的，即在发行它们的国家运送邮件。正是如此，是的。而且这些邮票，即使它们有争议，也非常有趣，因为美国流行文化不仅仅存在于美国。它是一种国际出口产品。
And stamps are now part of that too. And so it's kind of cool to see our culture because US pop culture doesn't just exist in the US. It's an international export. And stamps are now part of that too. And so it's kind of cool to see our culture reflected back to us in the form of these international stamps. Yeah, and for collectors, it gives you way more variety than you get with US commemorative stamps. Definitely. And if you're a fan of an artist,
邮票现在也成了其中的一部分。看到我们的文化很有趣，因为美国流行文化不仅仅存在于美国，它是一种国际出口产品。邮票现在也成了其中的一部分。所以，看到我们的文化以这些国际邮票的形式反映给我们，感觉很酷。是的，对于收藏家来说，它提供的种类比美国纪念邮票要多得多。确实如此。如果你是一位艺术家的粉丝，
this might be the only chance you'll have to see them on a stamp. For example, we might not see a Tina Turner stamp for a few years in the US, if we see one at all, but you can go online and find a stamp from Grenada from 1988 with Tina Turner. And that same issue they have Madonna and Elton John and Bruce Springsteen.
这可能是你能在邮票上看到他们的唯一机会。例如，我们可能几年内在美国都看不到蒂娜·特纳的邮票，甚至根本看不到，但你可以在网上找到一张1988年格林纳达发行的蒂娜·特纳邮票。在同一套邮票中，他们还有麦当娜、埃尔顿·约翰和布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀。
And you can buy those and own a little piece of that history for not very much money. So does this influence the US Postal Service to maybe issue more pop culture stamps, maybe with stars from other countries too? Well, so since the 90s, it's become a bit more complicated to put pop culture icons from anywhere on a stamp, in part because of how sophisticated the pop culture industry has become, the Elvis estate worked closely with the Postal Service on an Elvis stamp, but that's not always how these things go. Daniel Piazza at the Smithsonian Postal Museum told me about it. You don't have to pay royalties for a statue of George Washington
你可以花很少的钱买下它们，拥有一小段历史。那么，这是否会影响美国邮政署发行更多的流行文化邮票，或许还会加入其他国家的明星？嗯，自90年代以来，将任何地方的流行文化偶像印在邮票上变得更加复杂，部分原因是流行文化产业已经变得非常成熟。猫王遗产管理委员会曾与邮政署就猫王邮票进行过密切合作，但事情并不总是这样发展的。史密森尼邮政博物馆的丹尼尔·皮亚扎告诉了我这一点。你不需要为乔治·华盛顿的雕像支付版税，
in the Capitol building to put it on a stamp, but with all of these sports legends and Hollywood actors and singers, these are years of complicated negotiations, sometimes with their estates to get the right licensing and permissions and images. And you have to go to all of the descendants, or at least the sort of legally entitled descendants, and make sure that they agree with and approve of the image that's used and so forth.
就可以把它印在国会大厦的邮票上，但对于所有这些体育传奇、好莱坞演员和歌手来说，这需要多年的复杂谈判，有时还需要与他们的遗产管理方进行谈判，以获得正确的许可、授权和图像。你必须找到所有的后代，或者至少是法律上有权继承的后代，确保他们同意并批准所使用的图像等等。
Such a mess. As soon as one thing gets easier, you know, like the idea of what is worth commemorating, all the lawyers get involved to make it worse. Oh, well, so maybe they're just kind of balanced in the universe when it comes to celebrity stamps. I think so. Yeah, but I do love the idea of getting a Michelle Fifer stamp from somewhere like Sierra Leone. That's just a stunning thing to know that that exists or it could exist in the world. Thank you so much Gabe, this is awesome. Thank you.
真是太麻烦了。一旦某件事变得容易了，比如关于什么值得纪念的想法，所有的律师就会介入，让事情变得更糟。哦，好吧，所以当涉及到名人邮票时，宇宙可能只是处于一种平衡状态。我想是这样。是的，但我真的很喜欢从塞拉利昂之类的地方获得一张米歇尔·菲佛邮票的想法。知道它的存在或者它可能存在于世界上，这真是一件令人惊叹的事情。非常感谢你，盖布，这太棒了。谢谢。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Gabe Bullard and edited by Delaney Hall with additional editing by Kelly Prime, sound mix by Dara Hirsch, fact checking by Graham Haysha, music by Swan Riao. Kathy too is our executive producer, Kurt Colstedt is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Le, Jason Dillion, Lashemadon,
本周的《99% Invisible》由盖布·布拉德制作，德莱尼·霍尔编辑，凯利·普莱姆协助编辑，达拉·赫什负责混音，格雷厄姆·海沙负责事实核查，斯旺·里奥负责配乐。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特是我们的数字总监。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·勒、杰森·迪里昂、拉舍马顿，
Jacob Moltenado Medina, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. We are part of this literature and serious exam podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. Eric and me Roman Mars. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
雅各布·莫尔特纳多·梅迪纳、乔·罗森伯格，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是这个文学与严肃考试播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。埃里克和我，罗曼·马尔斯。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及《99PI》的所有往期节目。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。